[MUSIC PLAYING]
JACQUELINE FULLER:
Welcome, everyone.
Thanks so much for joining us.
I'm Jaclyn Jacqueline
Fuller, and I'm
the President of Google.org.
We're Google's
philanthropy, and we've
focused on exactly the topic
of today's secession-- building
for everyone using tech
to change the world.
Google.org invests
money as well as
our Googlers, the
time of our Googlers,
especially our tech Googlers.
You might have heard
Sundar mention recently
that we're investing a billion
dollars over the next five
years on Google.org so
we can help find and fund
some of the best innovators
around the world who
are using technology
in really clever ways
to change the world.
And today, we're going to meet
a few of our partners, grantees,
who are doing exactly that.
So why don't we
start by just hearing
a little bit about each one of
you, and telling your story.
Maybe Jess, we can
start with you.
And if you could give
us just maybe a sentence
on who you are personally,
how you came to this issue.
And maybe a sentence about the
problem, and then a sentence
about what the
solution looks like.
JESS LADD: Great.
Hi, my name is Jess Lad,
and I'm the founder and CEO
of Callisto.
Callisto is a online sexual
misconduct reporting platform
that helps find
serial offenders,
so that if a victim
of sexual misconduct
doesn't want to come forward
unless they know that there's
another person, we connect
them with other victims,
and with their options
for taking action
to protect their community.
And I came to this work
because I was sexually
assaulted in college, and I went
through the reporting process.
And I ended up finding
the act of reporting
to be more traumatic
than the assault.
So trying to figure out
how, when somebody has faced
something like this, they can
use a system that actually
rebuilds their sense of
agency and empowerment,
rather than taking it
away all over again.
And ultimately,
helps find an end
stop particularly serial
offenders, but all offenders
and create a real deterrent
towards this type of behavior
towards other human beings.
And we launched Callisto three
years ago on college campuses,
and this summer,
we're expanding it
to address sexual assault and
coercion in the tech industry.
JACQUELINE FULLER: All
right, thanks, [INAUDIBLE]..
Right?
OLIVER HURST HILLER: Hi,
I'm Oliver Hurst Hiller.
I run engineering and
product at DonorsChoose.org.
Thank you to Jacqueline
and Google.org
for hosting us today.
Honored to be up here with
these other social entrepreneurs
and change makers.
DonorsChoose.org.
We are like Kickstarter
or GoFundMe,
except that we're a
nonprofit, and we're
focused exclusively on public
schools here in the US.
Teachers bring their best
ideas to our website for things
they want to do with their
classroom for their classroom
that their schools
can't otherwise afford,
and we help bring the
dollars to those projects
to help bring them to life.
At 80% of the schools
in the US, there's
a teacher who's
used our web site.
We're really excited
about that reach
because there's about 100,000
public schools in the US.
More than a million
classroom projects
have been funded on the
site, delivering resources
to about 28 million
public school students.
And the dollars have come from
more than 3 million donors,
who, in total, have
given almost $700 billion
to classrooms through
our organization.
JACQUELINE FULLER: All right.
ALEX BARNADOTTE:
Hello, everyone.
My name is Alex
Barnadotte, and I'm
the founder and CEO of an
organization called Beyond 12.
We are a high tech, high
touch coaching platform,
and our mission is to
significantly increase
the number of students
from low income communities
who graduate from our nation's
colleges and universities.
And like I said, we do that
through a coaching platform,
both a human, a
virtual human coach.
So we hire recent
college graduates
who themselves are the
first in their families
to go to college so they
understand firsthand,
the challenges that our students
are facing on their road
to a college graduation, on
their road to a college degree.
And we pair our human
coaches with a mobile app
called My Coach,
where we've downloaded
the academic and financial
aid calendars of the colleges
and universities that
students are attending.
We synthesize the data into
an interactive comprehensive
to do list for them
that we augment
with customized evidence
based push notifications
and nudges to remind
them of the activities,
deadlines, and behaviors
that lead to success.
And on the back end, we
have an analytics engine
that's powered by
machine learning that
allows us to predict which
students need our help
and when, and prescribe
the right type of support,
whether it be human,
digital, or both.
We're B to B, so we work with
high schools and colleges.
We're currently serving
about 50,000 students,
and on our way to serving
a million students by 2025.
I started Beyond 12 in large
part because of the challenges
I faced as a first
generation college goer.
So I was born in Port
Au Prince, Haiti.
I grew up in inner city Boston.
I was the first person in
my family to go to college.
We traveled to
Hanover, New Hampshire,
because I landed at
Dartmouth, thinking
that the most difficult part
of the journey was behind us,
and we thought we had made it.
When we got that
acceptance letter,
we thought we won the
lottery, this is it.
As you can imagine, because
of the work that I do,
it wasn't it.
I completely bombed
my freshman year--
academically,
socially, emotionally,
and discovered that getting
in was only the first step.
Luckily, I was able
to turn things around.
I did get my degree,
went to grad school out
here at Stanford.
But each year, about
700,000 students
with backgrounds and stories
similar to mine embark
on their college journeys
believing that they are
prepared for the road ahead.
But the statistics
tell us that only 9%
of students from low
income communities
can expect to earn a bachelor's
degree by their mid 20s
versus 77% of their
higher income peers.
So we are hoping to
change those statistics
through a combination of
human and technology solution.
JACQUELINE FULLER: All right.
[APPLAUSE]
Phil.
PHILLIP ATIBA GOFF: I
am Phillip Atiba Goff.
I am the co-founder and
President of the Center
for Policing Equity.
My story and CPE came about, I
was born at a very young age.
We should probably skip
ahead a little bit.
JACQUELINE FULLER: One sentence.
PHILLIP ATIBA
GOFF: One sentence.
We started that, but I'll
go with the president here.
We work inside of
police departments
to help them be less
racist, and we do it
at the behest of
law enforcement.
I know that might sound strange,
but it's absolutely the case
that many folks in law
enforcement from around
the country are asking
for help to reduce
the racial disparities
in what they're doing.
That becomes really hard when
you don't have data on it.
So we started in 2012, the
national justice database.
That is the first and the
largest standardized database
of police behavior.
We now cover about a
third of the United States
by population.
And here's the
amazing thing-- when
we get numbers is
we can hold people
accountable to actual values.
The hard part now is getting
that data to be cleaned,
and getting it standardized.
That takes a lot of time.
It takes human beings,
every single department,
about nine to 12 months to
standardize it, and audit it,
and analyze it.
But with the help of
our Google engineers,
we've reduced that to about nine
to 12 days in the last year.
We're trying to get
to nine to 12 minutes
by the end of this year.
And when we've got
when we get there,
we can measure not
just disparities,
but actual bias, right?
The part of the disparities
that belongs to law enforcement
policy and individuals.
And with that, just like they
do with all their other stats
on crime, all their other
stats on public welfare,
they can hold themselves
accountable to it,
and reduce the
disparities and the burden
from this on each of
those communities.
So that's the ways in which we
can get behavioral science--
we call us the justice nerds--
to combine with tech-- that
would be the justice geeks--
and we can do great cool things.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Awesome.
[APPLAUSE]
Well, I think you can
see that we've got heroes
amongst us, who are day in
and day out using technology
to change the world.
And you know what, they
need people like you.
So we're going to have
opportunities for interaction
with them after
this session if you
would like to get to know
them better, know their work,
maybe even volunteer with them.
But why don't we
dig in a little bit
and go back to the
technology itself?
And if you'd be willing just
to speak a bit about exactly
what you're doing from
a technology perspective
that you think might be
interesting to this audience.
Phil kind of kicked us off.
Alex, do you want to tell
us what you all are doing?
ALEX BARNADOTTE:
Yeah, absolutely.
Just to follow up on
sort of our solution.
So we're trying to solve the
issue of college success.
And we believe that there is
both a human and a technology
solution for it, right?
And I know that I
might be in this room
where we believe that there's
an app for everything.
And we believe that
there is also an app.
But for us, technology is the
amplifier of our humans, right?
So we had human
coaches, and we're
trying to figure out how do you
amplify the support that they
are providing to
students, and what's
the best way for us to do that.
And so we built a platform
that allows us to do that.
So we haven't completely
removed our humans,
but we are making our
humans most effective,
and really trying
to figure out, what
are the aspects
of student support
that can be automated
and digitized.
The navigational and
the transactional
can be digitized and automated.
And what are the aspects
of student support
that are uniquely human.
And what we've
heard from students,
those are the
inspirational, right?
And so, do I belong here,
am I college material,
I'm having challenges
and struggles.
So we've built a
solution that allows
us to distinguish between
those kinds of supports,
and offer a just in time
solution for students.
And on the back end, this is
the really important piece--
that we are going to get to
the point where we're serving
millions of students annually--
we needed a solution
that allowed
us to predict which students
needed our help and when,
and then prescribe the
right type of support.
So that's how we're
incorporating machine learning
into our solution to do a
little bit of the predictive
and the prescriptive modeling
that allows us to scale
our efforts, so that
we can serve students,
but also, so that
we can provide them
with the exact type of support
that they need at the moment
that they need it to prevent
them from dropping out.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Great.
Oliver, how about you?
OLIVER HURST HILLER: Yeah,
I'll share a cool example
of how we're applying
technology also
in the machine learning arena.
But first, some things
about DonorsChoose.org
that some folks may
not know and that
are not typical in the
crowd funding world.
First, on the fulfillment side,
when a project on our web site
reaches its goal, all
the funding it needed--
$600, $700-- we don't send
cash, we don't send a check.
We actually buy the stuff, and
we ship it to the classroom.
Or if it's a field trip,
we'll pay the bus company.
And this adds significant
operational complexity,
but it's core to what we do, and
we're going to keep doing it.
And similarly, every project
that goes live on our site
doesn't just go up there
like say, a GoFundMe.
We have a human being
review every single project.
And the good news is, it's
done by people who are
much more qualified than I am.
We have a core of a
couple hundred teachers
who have been successful
on the website,
and successful on the
classroom, and they're
helping to publish live
about 1,000 classroom project
requests every day, just to
give you a sense for the volume.
So they're doing a killer job.
But one of the challenges
that we anticipate
is that as we grow and grow,
or we get spikes in volume,
we're not sure how
well this scales.
So we connected our
data science team and--
team might be overstating
it, because we
have two data scientists.
We connected our data
science team of two
with the good folks at Kaggle.
And if you're not
familiar with Kaggle,
Kaggle is Google's crowdsourced
data science community.
So folks with data
chops organize
around data challenges.
And together with Kaggle,
we launched this challenge
to see if we could
automate this vetting.
So could we have
machines and algorithms
apply the same sort
of rigor and feedback
for the teachers
submitting projects
that today is done
by humans, maybe
to offset some of that
volume that we're seeing.
And the good news
as those of you
familiar with AI and
machine learning,
is that the training
data set that we're
able to give to this
community was pretty big.
So we gave them
a couple of years
worth of screening information,
a couple of 100,000
projects submitted to
our site, and either
approved, or rejected, and
iterated, and then approved.
And each project in that
data set was pretty rich.
So it has an essay written
by the teacher, which
is a couple hundred words.
It's got every single
resource that they
requested for their classrooms.
So books, or technology,
or the field trip details.
And then we've got the
meta data around the school
or around the classroom, like
the subject, or the grade
level, or the poverty level.
So it's a pretty rich data set.
And we ran this contest
with Kaggle for two months.
It just ended a few weeks ago.
600 data scientists
participated.
6,000 algorithms were submitted.
And it just ended.
We're still digging through
the details and the results,
but the good news is
that we can already
see that the top submissions
way outperformed anything
we were able to do on our own.
And so this is pretty
exciting, right?
This is an operational scary
scaling problem that we had,
and data science and
machine learning community
was able to step up.
And hopefully, the
results mean that we
may be able to more effectively
help even more classrooms.
JACQUELINE FULLER:
That's amazing.
Maybe even some people
in this audience
were part of the teams
that responded to that.
So shifting gears a little
bit, here in Silicon Valley,
we're very
comfortable with risk.
But in the world
of philanthropy,
in the world of nonprofits,
not so much, right?
So I want to just
ask you about risk,
and maybe risk that you've
had to take either personally
or professionally.
How that's played out, how
that goes in the culture.
Would you like to start us?
PHILLIP ATIBA GOFF: Sure.
I'm from West Philadelphia,
literally born and raised.
I lived in Bel Air for a time.
Go ahead, sing the song
in your head, it's fine.
But going into a
police department,
and doing the work
of figuring out
how to clean their
excruciatingly ugly data--
it wasn't just scary as
a black person walking
into a law enforcement space,
it was scary as an academic.
You don't get any credit
for doing something
that shifts the needle
on public policy
when your job is to get
tenure and to create
new knowledge, which is the
job description for a faculty
member.
So as a faculty
member, that was scary.
But the scarier part
I think right now
is building the organization
that's necessary,
the infrastructure
that's necessary to keep
all this stuff going.
What you're seeing up here
is a bunch of folks who are--
I mean, social
entrepreneurship requires
that you build something
kind of with your hands,
and hold it together
until there's
enough revenue coming in that
it can hold itself together.
I don't have a degree in that.
I have a degree in many, many
other things, but not in that.
So figuring it out and building
the boat as we're going along,
and then now moving into
a space where technology
can solve so many
of these problems,
can automate this, and put
this in the hands of the 18,000
police departments across
the country, each of whom
have a homebrewed data
management process--
it is part of what is
keeping me up at night.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Yeah.
I mean, it's amazing to think
that you're having these police
agencies come to us.
They want to work together.
They're giving their
data voluntarily.
I mean, you're right on
the cutting edge of some
of our biggest racial
issues as a country,
and it's exciting to see both
sides coming together to say,
let's let the data and
the evidence really
drive the discussion here.
PHILLIP ATIBA
GOFF: Yeah, 1,000%.
It was shocking to
me the first thing
that anybody asked
when they say I
do this, like, oh, so you must
sue the police departments.
No.
So you must get it from
the public data sets.
I said, no.
Well, where do you
get their data.
They come to me, they say,
please, Dr. Blackenstein,
would you please tell
us how racist we are.
And believe it or not--
I get that kind of regularly,
that's my other code name--
and it's because they're used
to using data to hold themselves
accountable to crime.
The DNA of any police department
is a thing called comstat.
And comsat, they go and they
say what time the crime is
occurring, where
it is on the map,
and then they do this thing
called putting cops on dops.
And that helps to
reduce the crime.
The problem has been
on racial disparities
is that disparities could
be because of crime rates.
It could be because
of poverty, something
that the police department
not really accountable for.
So what we've done is
we've used census data,
we've used survey data from
the officers, and survey data
from the residents, with
their behavioral data
that they do not share
with anybody else.
And we said, this
is how we give you
the comsat for justice
in your department.
JACQUELINE FULLER:
That's amazing.
All right.
So Jess, equally
another topic right
in the crosshairs of
American society right now,
couldn't be any more
relevant or topical.
I'm sure you have
encountered some
personal, and professional,
and organizational risk.
JESS LADD: Sure.
So personally, I had to decide
about five years ago about
whether or not I
wanted to talk publicly
about my sexual
assault. And I think
for people who
want to make change
on the highly stigmatized
areas, and if you
want to found a
company in that area,
it's really hard to do
without talking about why
you care about that issue.
And a lot of these issues
are very hard to talk about,
and people aren't used
to talking about them
with their parents,
the people they're
dating, with their friends.
And so I had to decide whether
or not to kind of like out
myself in order to
work in this area.
And even now, I think what's
an organizational challenge is
that if there is a program
officer at a foundation who
gets what we're doing on a deep
level because they faced it,
that's very hard for them
to come to their boss
and say, no, I know this is
a good idea, and here's why.
If somebody donates
to us, and now
they want to get their friends
on board or throw a fundraiser,
they have to say why they
care about this organization,
and again, are they having
to out themselves too.
So in stigmatized areas
where we haven't quite
gotten to the point where
people are comfortable telling
their own personal narratives
related to the topic,
it's really hard to
fundraise, actually,
and it's a little
bit challenging
to get off the ground.
Because while everybody feels
the problem at a high level,
it's hard to relate
to it personally
if we can't talk about it and
share about it with each other.
I think the second kind of
big challenge for us is what
we're doing is really risky.
Like, we're trying to create
a safe place for victims
of sexual assault
and sexual harassment
to share with us the deepest
secrets of their lives.
And then we need
to protect those.
We need to protect
those from lawyers,
we need to protect
those from hackers,
we need to take a tremendous
amount of care with the data
that people aren't
trusting us with.
Because what we're asking of
people is to create an account,
and to save what happened
to them time stamped.
Now why this is important
is that on average college
survivors take 11 months to make
their report of sexual assault,
by which time it's
really hard for anyone
to do an investigation.
It's really hard for them
to remember it clearly.
And it's really hard
for action to be taken.
So if you can allow somebody
the ability to process what
happened to them closer to
the event, to write it down,
to document it in a way
that they feel safe,
and that you're not prompting
them to write down things
they're not sure of, because
then it'll be used to,
say, that's
conflicting testimony
later if they come on,
it's really important
that you're prompting
them to do that correctly,
and that you're
securing those data.
And if they want
to use our system
to figure out if
there's other victims
of the same
perpetrator, then we're
asking them to put in
the name, and a series
of unique identifiers, like
cell phone number, or Facebook
URL about their perpetrator.
And in the event of a
match, meaning somebody else
naming the same predator.
We connect them with a
Callisto options counselor
who, like you, we
provide services combined
with tech, who's an attorney
or under the supervision
of an attorney, who talks
to each victim separately
to get the sense of
their case, gives them
a sense of their options.
And if appropriate,
connects them together
to decide what to do next.
Including everything from
confronting the perpetrator
about their behavior, to
going to HR, to going public,
to going to the police, to
finding a lawyer, et cetera.
This means though that we
are not only again holding
really sensitive data, but
if we're doing our job,
We're bringing down some very
influential very powerful,
very well networked,
very rich people.
We're building a
system to bring down
the Weinsteins of the
world, to bring down
the politicians of the
the CEOs of companies.
What we're trying to
do is highly likely
to be attacked from lots
of different directions,
and we need to take that
charge very seriously.
We need to make sure that
we're not launching anything
that we're not sure of which,
means we have to build slowly,
and carefully in a lot
of ways, whereas you just
want to go fast as a start up.
But you can't fail fast
with something like this.
You can't fail
something like this.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Let me just
open this up to all of you.
So you have this room here
of self-selected folks
who I think are passionately
interested in this topic
of technology for social impact.
I want you to think back to
some aha moments and insights
that you've had
along your journey.
And think, what do
you know now that you
wish you had known in the
beginning of your journey
and advice that
you have for people
who are interested in
applying technology
for humanitarian impact.
Anyone want to
start us off there?
OLIVER HURST HILLER:
My advice would
be to leverage peer
groups for advice
and for continual learning.
The example I'll
share is called CTOs
for Good, which is a group that
I co-founded some years back.
And it's the people
who run engineering
at what I consider some of the
most tech forward non-profits
on the planet.
We've got about 20
orgs participating now,
including Callisto, Kiva,
Code for America, Wikipedia,
Khan Academy, code.org, Charity
Water, Global Citizen, Crisis
Text Line, and others.
It's an amazing group.
And we meet annually.
We have a two day
mini conference
with a very active email list.
And what we're doing
is helping each other
in a safe space, trusted space.
We talk about technical
challenges, vendors
to avoid, hiring challenges,
all sorts of things.
And now there are similar peer
groups in other disciplines
like marketing and operations.
And also up and
down the tech stack.
So we've got DevOps for good,
and IT for good, and data
science for good.
And look, the nonprofit
world has there's challenges.
We typically have
fewer resources
and tighter budgets than
our for profit compatriots
in those sectors.
But one of our advantages
is that we usually
can share more
openly, and share more
freely than other
industries, which
have to be more secretive.
So that's my advice--
is that ability to
share to your advantage.
ALEX BARNADOTTE: Awesome.
I think two pieces
of advice for me.
The first is I do
a lot of coaching
of young social
entrepreneurs, and I often
find that folks sort of have
created a solution that is
in search of a problem, right?
Like, I have this great
app, I have this great tool,
and I'm trying to figure
out ways to apply it
to a social problem.
And my advice would be to
switch to the paradigm, right?
Like what is the social
challenge about which you
are most passionate.
About which you sort of
want to spend or for which
you want to spend a lot of time.
And then think about what
that solution would be.
And the reminder that
technology is a tool--
it is not the solution.
It is a tool.
And so really to reframe the
sort of challenge and solution
pipeline--
that's probably a
little bit different
than we think about it when
we are in rooms like this.
The second piece
is the importance
of engaging your clients
and users as designers right
I think often time
in the communities
that we're operating
in folks who
live in the communities have a
lot of ideas for the solutions.
What's missing is
the opportunity
to create organizations the
way that we create them.
So as you are thinking
about solutions,
and as you are
thinking about what
are the challenges,
really, really important
to get users as designers.
Not as consultants, not
participating in focus groups
after you've already
come up with a solution.
But can you engage folks
in that design process
so that you are creating
a solution that actually
is applicable and relevant
to the communities
that you wish to serve.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Advice?
PHILLIP ATIBA GOFF: I get
uncomfortable giving advice
because I have to live with
the life that I've chosen.
So when asked to give
advice, I usually
give what my dad has told me.
If you want to be a philosopher,
go where philosophers go.
He stole that from
William James,
and also, no one should
want to be a philosopher.
My dad was one, that's difficult
at the dinner table early on.
But we took that advice when the
Google immersion team came in.
They did ride alongs
with law enforcement.
JACQUELINE FULLER:
Just as a side note.
The Google immersion team is
when we send our engineers,
product managers, UX designers,
volunteers from Google
to work side by side.
PHILLIP ATIBA
GOFF: That's right.
And before we got
started writing code,
the first thing they did
was do the ride alongs.
They talked with folks, they
went to training at NYPD.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Ride
alongs with the police.
PHILLIP ATIBA GOFF: Ride
along with law enforcement .
And before I ever started
doing this work, when I just
had my regular degree in
psychological science,
I went and spent a month
embedded in the Denver Police
Department.
And the violence that I
thought I was going experience
was really different violence.
It was more close up,
it was more intimate.
It didn't take the shape
that I thought it would.
The racism that I thought I was
going to see, which I figured
would like old school racism,
it was really, really different.
And so being where
the people are
when making these
decisions, this
is the users as designers--
being in the ecosystem
where the problem is
allows for the solution to
become the thing that they
always knew that
they needed, but they
couldn't see because they
were too close to it.
If you don't get
close enough to it,
then you're going to
able to see any of it.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Right.
As Brian Stevenson
says, you've got
to get approximate, both on
the problem and the solutions.
Jess.
JESS LADD: I think one
of my big learnings
was realizing that my job
is not to build a tech
product for victims.
It is to build a company,
but outside of that, even
the larger offering of
what we're providing,
a tech product doesn't work
if people don't know about it.
People won't know about it if
you don't figure out how you're
going to market it to them.
Chances are, your customer
is not the same as your user
if you're building a
lot of tech for good.
And so if you get so
focused on building
the product for your
end user, you'll
lose a lot of the different
partnerships that you need.
So I think it's good to
map out the whole system.
Like, who is it, who needs
to buy your product, what
do they care about, embed
with them in addition
to the end users.
Know what they want.
How is your end user
going to learn about it.
What's the best way
to get it to them.
Get a sense of
their space, and get
a sense of what they
want when they get there.
But I think I got so
focused on the end results,
that I didn't
understand the full path
that the whole system.
JACQUELINE FULLER: So
it sounds like you guys
have everything in hand and
everything's going really well.
But maybe there's
one or two things
that keep you up at night.
Maybe just something that
if this thing goes sideways,
it could be the undoing.
Anyone want to share about
what's keeping you up at night?
JESS LADD: I mean, I'm paranoid
about security for sure.
And the certainty that
we're going to get sued.
It's less of a worry
that you're going
to get sued when you know
it's going to happen.
It's more just like, how are
we going to address this well.
And things like,
how are we going
to create attorney-client
privilege electronically.
Like, there's not a lot
of precedent for that.
How do we match on
data that we can't
see, because we know it's
going to get subpoenaed,
so we need to make sure
that we're matching this.
We're using linear
secret sharing,
and we're federating
our servers.
And we're doing a lot of
just fairly complicated
cutting edge technology.
Whereas normally, if you're
building tech for good,
you don't want to be building in
that stuff unless you need it.
Like, often, a Google
form will do the trick
to a lot of issues.
But in our case, we do.
And so it is sort of
setting new precedent
in a lot of different areas,
which is a little scary.
And at the moment, we're
hiring a lot of people.
So finding the right
people for the team
at a really critical
stage and growth,
including senior leadership
is always a little scary.
Because the future of your
company is your people.
PHILLIP ATIBA GOFF: The
thing that keeps me up
at night honestly, the thing
that I can't find a way
to make jokes about,
is that people
will get bored with the
suffering of the communities
that we deal with.
In 2014, when Ferguson
caught on fire, and Baltimore
shortly thereafter,
we had been doing
this work for almost
10 years prior to that,
and nobody cared.
And what I've seen since then is
both heartening and depressing.
So this past year, we estimated
that philanthropic giving
nationally to criminal justice
reform across the United States
was about $220 million.
That's way more
than it used to be.
But of that budget,
about $10 million
for re-entry and
reintegration, $200 million
is for decarceration, and
$10 million is for policing.
That's scary for me not just
because the resources are
so small to get this work
done, but because what
we do every day is we go
between the communities
where there are kids
who refer to themselves
as the throwaway people.
To the departments
that hear that,
and don't know how to do better.
And so what we find ourselves
doing in the times that are not
the good times,
is begging people
to care enough that
the relationships
between the
departments that care,
and the people that need
them can be strengthened
the way that they should be.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Well,
in our last few minutes
here-- and I'll
say, for those who
are interested in having
a deeper conversation,
making a personal connection
with our heroes here
and, the organizations they
represent, after this talk,
we're going to be out in the
grassy area by the totem pole.
Just up a little bit from
there on the platform,
we've got that area
reserved for conversation
if folks want to come in and
have some one on one Q&A.
But in general, you've got
this self-selected group,
this room full of
technologists who
are obviously very curious about
this, want to get involved.
So what's your call to action?
How can these folks get involved
and help carry the load?
JESS LADD: We're
hiring engineers.
Our code is open source.
It's up on GitHub, check
it out, contribute.
And if you think that
your employer, or school,
or conference, or whoever
should adopt Callisto
so that all of their
members can get the access,
suggests them online
at ProjectCallisto.org.
OLIVER HURST HILLER: So our
first collaboration with Kaggle
to automate the screening
of classroom projects
that I told you about was
so successful that we're
doing another Kaggle challenge.
The focus is around reengaging
donors to return to the site
and support more classrooms.
So for example, we have 40,
50, 60,000 classroom project
requests live on the
site at any one time.
Could we recommend
just a couple that
would resonate with a specific
donor that would make them more
likely to open their wallet.
And fundraising and
reengaging donors
are critically important to
any org that does fundraising,
but this for us is an
especially hairy challenge
because many of our donors
only give once or twice.
So we don't have a lot of
signal there to work with.
So if you've got data
chops, and you're curious,
please go check out
kaggle.com/donorschoose/io,
and you can learn more there.
There it is.
Also, for those of you that have
kids or teachers in the family,
you may know that this week is
national Teacher Appreciation
Week.
All week, Google is
generously doubling donations
to many projects.
And the way it works is that
each day, the donations,
the match is focused
on different project
categories that are super
important to teachers.
So today, the focus is music.
The idea is, let's
support those students who
want to learn music, the
teachers who are helping
them develop their talent.
So you can go to
DonorsChoose.org/googlemusic.
Pick a classroom to support.
Google will double
your donation.
So thank you to Google
for that generosity
and thank you to
all the teachers
out there who are doing the
hard work to bring the best out
of our kids.
JACQUELINE FULLER: All
right, thanks, Oliver.
ALEX BARNADOTTE: Awesome.
OK, I have a couple of things.
The first one is really
simple and really easy.
We are increasing our
social media presence.
So if you could just go
and follow @Beyond12--
is it coming up anywhere?
PHILLIP ATIBA GOFF: Yes.
ALEX BARNADOTTE: OK,
it's coming up somewhere,
but it's @B-E-Y-O-N-D-1-2.
@Beyond12.
We're going to tweet lots
of interesting things.
There is a TEDx talk
that we just did
that we would love to amplify.
So if you watch it, you
feel inspired, please
feel free to amplify IT.
Just follow us as we're sort of
like amping up our social media
efforts.
The second one is we too
are hiring engineers.
So we have been outsourcing
our development,
and we just hired a CTO.
And we're looking
for engineering help
in whatever form it comes in.
So definitely
tweet at us and let
us know if you're interested.
Particularly looking for
folks who have ML experience.
And then the third one
is much more personal.
so we work with students who
are graduating from college
who are also thinking about
their first jobs, who have not
had the opportunities that
a lot of us who are sitting
on the stage have had.
So when you think about
your own personal career,
and as you are climbing
your own ladders of success,
I just want to ask you
to take a step back
to think about who
are you pulling along
with you right who may have
different experiences that you
have.
So when you think about who
you're mentoring at Google,
when you think about who
you're hiring at Google,
and when you think about
your own personal philosophy,
how can you sort of
embed the principles
that you've heard from all
of us in your own personal
and professional
journey so that you
can increase
opportunity and insure
that a child's zip code
no longer determines
his or her destiny
JACQUELINE FULLER: Phil.
PHILLIP ATIBA GOFF:
So three things.
First, please do follow
us on social media.
I'm @ DrPhilGoff-- that's
the other Dr. Phil.
You can also follow
@policingequity.
You can also sign up
to be a #justicenerd,
I brought the t-shirt.
So we just had our first
group of young justice nerds,
so you can hashtag that.
But amplify the
messages that way.
A second, apparently,
it's going around--
we are in the process
of pre-hiring a CTO,
and we also have a group of
volunteer software engineers.
So if folks are interested,
you can get in touch
with us via social media.
We're at policingequity.org.
And the third one, this is a way
to get involved more generally
when we're talking about
police accountability.
In every city that you live
in in the United States,
you can call your
police department
not to report something,
but to request a ride along.
That ride along is
just get in a car,
you spend a couple
of hours going
and see what law
enforcement does.
And I have never had
it happen that someone
goes through a ride long,
and has that experience,
and doesn't want to do
something to reward folks just
to make that space a
different, more vital, safer,
and more fair space.
It's a two to three hour
commitment, a phone call,
a little bit of awkwardness.
You don't have to wear the
vest if you don't want to.
But I highly
encourage folks do it.
There's almost nothing
more eye opening
in terms of how you
relate to public safety
than the ability to go and
take one of those I encourage
everybody to do that.
JACQUELINE FULLER: So that's
the most specific call to action
I think I've ever heard.
All right, in our last
just a couple minutes
here, why don't we end in a
moment of inspiration and hope.
If you guys want to share just
one thing that gives you hope.
I'll start.
It gives me hope that
this session sold out,
and they had to put us in
the largest room available,
because all of you are so
interested in this topic,
and you all bring a skill set
that is desperately needed.
And that gives me hope.
PHILLIP ATIBA GOFF:
When Ferguson blew up,
and we saw Baltimore get ugly,
and the rest of the country
was consumed with
the issues of police
violence for several
years, the head of the FBI
commented that he
was embarrassed
because we had no idea
how many people got shot
by law enforcement every year.
The federal government
didn't have any idea.
By the time that we next to
elect a president in 2020,
we will have enough data to
give a national snapshot,
not just of disparities in
police use of deadly force,
or just disparities in
police use of force,
but on racial bias on
all police behaviors.
That's because of
technologists like all of you,
because of behavioral
scientists like me
and my justice nerd
friends, and because of what
law enforcement
communities are requiring.
And that to me is one of
the best good news stories
on racism.
JACQUELINE FULLER:
That is great news.
[APPLAUSE]
ALEX BARNADOTTE: So I
have the incredible honor
of working with amazing young
people, college students,
high school students or
high school students who are
about to transition to college.
And what gives me hope is what
I have seen in this generation,
from the students in Parkland,
to Oakland, to Chicago,
to Dorchester, who are fighting
for their rights to be safe,
and who are demanding that we
adults stop and pay attention.
And I am incredibly inspired by
the spirit of intersectionality
that these young people are
operating with, and operating
with the creed that none of
us is free until all of us
are free.
And for me, that gives me hope.
I'm on Twitter, I'll
read a Facebook post,
and I'll read the latest
incident that is happening,
I remember those young people.
I think back to the way
that they have touched,
and moved, and started a
movement, and I'm inspired.
And think that we're
going to be OK.
We're going to be good.
OLIVER HURST HILLER: Whether
it's the response to our Kaggle
challenge, or the
participation of CTOs for Good,
or like Jacqueline said,
all of you being here,
that makes me
hopeful and grateful
because I see the tech community
rising to the occasion,
and wanting to give
back, wanting to make
a social impact, whether it's
full time or on a volunteering
basis.
And I think with
your superpowers,
we can really change things.
JACQUELINE FULLER: All right.
And Jess, why don't
you wrap us up?
JESS LADD: I'm going
to cheat and do two.
So the first is that about a
month ago, I was in New York
and I was visiting the Upright
Citizens Brigade Theater, which
is a comedy troupe and training
school for young comedians.
And I was talking to some of the
actors there, and one of them
said to me, she was like,
there were always people
who we kind of knew about.
It was sort of an open secret,
but nothing really happened.
And within two months after
Callisto had launched,
those people were reported
and they weren't here anymore.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Wow.
JESS LADD: So to her,
to have that sense
that that had happened and
that quickly in her community
gave me a lot of hope.
And the second is that
back in June and July,
when Justin Caldbeck
had first happened,
and all of these different
venture capitalists
were getting outed, I started
looking into that space,
and I had, based on
those news articles,
had a very negative impression
of venture capitalists.
And then recently, over
the last three months,
I've been talking
to a lot of them
because we've actually
been fundraising from them.
And I've been going into
firms, and saying, hey,
does your VC firm
want to donate.
There is no financial ROI.
VC firms don't normally
do this, right?
This is not their thing.
Would you like to donate to
allow us to create a reporting
system to help founders report
sexual misconduct committed
by venture capitalists?
No idea if that would work.
Seems like they have every
incentive not to do that.
But about one in three
firms have said yes,
and now we have seven,
including Greylock,
including First Round,
a lot of great firms
who are donating to
support this work,
and actually want accountability
in their industry.
And so I think there
are a lot of people
who do care about this
issue, and you can't just
assume like, oh, because
most of you are a man,
or whatever, you're not in this.
Some of our best
allies have been men.
allies are the ones
that you'd expect the least.
And I think that
this is a problem
that so many people care about.
And if you just give them an
opportunity to be a part of it,
they will be.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Well,
thank you for everything
that you guys are doing to
give all of us so much hope.
So let's hear it
for these heroes.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]